außerirdische könnten in der lage seien
schwarze löcher für ihre zwecke zu
nutzen schon vor 50 jahren hatte der
englische physiker roger penrose diese
spektakuläre theorie aufgestellt demnach
könnte eine weiter entwickelte
zivilisation schwarze löcher als
kraftwerke nutzen um so energie zu
gewinnen jetzt ist es einem schottischen
forschungsteam gelungen genau diese
verrückte theorie mit hilfe eines realen
experiments zu belegen klicks um science
and future gibt es da einmal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
und nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen clixoom gibt
es übrigens auch auf die ohren und zwar
als podcast die links zu spotify und
apple podcast sind unten in der video
beschreibung unbedingt abonnieren es
wäre eine enorme technische leistung und
dazu sind nach ansicht des englischen
mathematikers und physikers roger
penrose nur weit entwickelte
zivilisation in der lage im klartext
also aliens diese könnten schwarze
löcher als kraftwerke nutzen und so
energie gewinnen die theorie von peñoles
sieht so aus benötigt wird zum einen ein
sich drehendes schwarzes loch um dieses
zur energiegewinnung zu nutzen müsste
ein objekt in dessen äußere schicht
befördert werden denn dort würde das
objekt negative energie werte annehmen
in einem weiteren schritt müsste das
objekt dann in zwei teile geteilt werden
die eine hälfte würde zurück ins
schwarze loch fallen
der andere teil würde zurückgestoßen
werden und genau diese rückstoß aktion
hätte es in sich denn dabei könnte durch
die zurückliegende hälfte energie aus
der rotation des schwarzen lochs
gewonnen werden so weit zumindest die
theorie und die beschäftigt fachleute
weltweit seitdem immer wieder so auch im
jahr 1961 damals wollte der physiker
jakovljevic diese these auf der erde
testen seine idee war es vertrete
lichtquellen auf einen sehr schnell
rotierenden zylinder treffen zu lassen
denn dann könnte der sogenannte rotation
stalker effekt greifen und die
lichtwellen von einer positiven in eine
negative frequenz verwandeln dabei würde
dem zylinder energie
die entzogen werden im klartext wären
die reflektierten lichtwellen also
energiereicher als die einfallenden
ziemlich verrückt aber das soll
funktionieren und einen ähnlichen ansatz
nutzte jetzt auch ein forschungsteam aus
glasgow dem es gelang die alte theorie
von roger penrose zu belegen
ihr könnt gespannt sein wie sie das
hinbekommen haben wie die schottischen
fachleute in einem aufsatz in nature
physics berichten nutzten sie
schaumstoff und lautsprecher für ihr
experiment okay konkret platzierten sie
einen kreis aus lautsprechern ließen
diesen rotieren
im experiment sollte diese anordnung das
schwarze loch darstellen deutlich
einfacher als die umsetzung mit einem
metallzylinder denn dieser hätte sich
mindestens eine milliarde mal pro
sekunde drehen müssen um ein schwarzes
loch zu simulieren stadtlicht wenn
wurden also verdrehte schallwellen
produziert verdreht durch die drehung
der lautsprecher denn durch deren
kleinere frequenz also als licht reicht
auch eine viel langsameren drehung aus
die verdrehten shulman liefen also durch
eine schaumstoff scheibe hindurch die
nicht nur rotierte sondern auch den
schall absorbierte hinter der scheibe
sollten die schallwellen per mikrofon
aufgezeichnet werden und tatsächlich
sobald die fachleute die scheibe nur
schnell genug drehten wechselte die
frequenz vom positiven zu negativen
werten im klartext heißt das also dass
auch hier der rotation doppler effekt
beobachtet werden konnte das experiment
zeigte den fachleuten auch was bei einer
noch schnelleren drehung der scheibe
passiert denn dann nämlich konnte ein
ton aufgezeichnet werden der um achtung
30% lauter war als der ursprüngliche ton
aus den lautsprechern das bedeutet also
dass die schallwellen an energie
gewonnen haben sie haben diese quasi aus
der drehung mitgenommen dazu die glasgow
forscherin marion kommt die an der
studie beteiligt war wenn die scheibe
schnell rotiert passiert etwas komisches
die frequenz des geräusches wechselt von
einer positiven frequenz in eine
negative und stiehlt dabei quasi in der
wie von der rotierenden oberfläche dabei
werden die geräusche der lautsprecher
zunächst immer leiser wenn sie auf die
scheibe treffen
doch je schneller diese rotiert um so
lauter wird es das geräusch ist am ende
also lauter als das original geräusch
schon ziemlich verrückt die fachleute
vergleichen dieses phänomen mit der
sirene eines krankenwagens ihr ton wirkt
deutlich höher wenn sich der
rettungswagen in unserer direkten nähe
befindet der grund dafür liegt darin
dass der schall gestaucht wird wenn der
krankenwagen mitsamt serie wegfällt
klingt das sie reden heute für unsere
ohren tiefer bei schneller fahrt schiebt
der krankenwagen die schallwellen vor
sich zusammen also in unsere richtung
denn er fährt quasi in sie hinein
die schallwellen hinter dem wagen
dagegen zieht auseinander und die
frequenz wird kleiner genau das wird von
physikerinnen und physikern als
sogenannter doppler effekt bezeichnet
doch auch andere forschende hatten in
der vergangenheit über schwarze löcher
als mögliche energiequelle nachgedacht
so zum beispiel archibald wheeler der
manchmal auch als schöpfer der schwarzen
löcher bezeichnet wird er hatte hoch
intelligente typ zwei zivilisationen im
kopf die stellare schwarze löcher als
energiequelle nutzen könnten mit hilfe
von kollektoren könnten außerirdische
die schwarzen löcher ummantelt haben um
so deren energie zu absorbieren kurze
erklärung die kosmische intelligenz gala
beschreibt typ 1 zivilisation als so
weit fortgeschritten dass sie die
gesamten energie ressourcen ihres
heimatplaneten ausschöpfen können
demnach haben sie die kontrolle über
energien von 4 mal 10 hoch neun kilowatt
zivilisationen des typs 2 sind noch
weiter sie können den kompletten energie
aufgrund ihres mutter gestürmt nutzen
das entspricht energien von 4 mal 10
hoch 3 und 20 kilowatt super
zivilisationen vom typ 3 können sogar
ihre gesamte galaxie als
energielieferant nutzen und verfügen
somit über energien von 14 hoch 34 diese
klassifikation über die verschiedenen
entwicklungsniveau es außerirdischer
intelligenzen stammt von dem politischen
astrophysiker nikola sainovic das chef
und basiert auf deren energieverbrauch
demnach gelangt jede zivilisation die
iren
kg verbrauch jahr für jahr erhöht nach
einigen jahrtausenden automatisch in die
nächst höhere stufe laut dem us physiker
michael karg befinden wir uns derzeit in
der übergangsphase von typ null zu eins
neben ihm bin ich übrigens autor dieser
sonderausgabe von stephen hawkings eine
kurze geschichte der zeit in der wir
hawkings leben in einem zusatz band aus
den unterschiedlichsten perspektiven
beleuchten kleine buchempfehlungen am
rande zurück zur nikola stevanovic
kardashian der hatte in einem interview
im jahr 1981 also gemutmaßt ob super
intelligenzen sich schon längst
supermassive schwarze löcher zu nutze
gemacht haben seiner theorie nach
könnten diese intelligenten wesen die
abgestrahlte energie der schwarzen
löcher im galaktischen zentrum abfangen
er sagte damals wir beobachten im
zentrum der galaxis eine sehr seltsame
punktförmige radio quelle die wir uns
bis jetzt noch nicht erklären können
eine unserer natürlichen erklärung ist
dass hinter dem phänomen ein schwarzes
loch steckt aber vielleicht steht dieses
objekt auch aufgrund seiner besonderen
position in der galaxis mit einigen
außerirdisch intelligenten aktivitäten
in zusammenhang
die rede ist von sagittarius a sternen
dem supermassereichen schwarzen loch mit
rund vier millionen sonnenmassen das
etwa 26.000 lichtjahre von der erde
entfernt ist darüber wusste die fachwelt
vor knapp 40 jahren kaum etwas
die fachleute aus glasgow sind also
nicht die einzigen und ersten die sich
mit dem thema beschäftigen
der us forscher david kipping hatte im
vergangenen jahr 2019 vorgeschlagen
schwarze löcher als eine art licht
schleuder zu nutzen so könnten
raumschiffe extreme geschwindigkeiten
erreichen und somit schnell und ohne
großen treibstoffverbrauch im all
umherreisen schwarze löcher also als
eine art express autobahn systeme im all
seine idee basiert auf den sogenannten
zwingen bei manövern eine technik die
bereits seit den voyager raumsonden
genutzt wird raumsonden können somit
quasi kostenlos energie tanken denn die
gravitationskraft der planeten wird
genutzt um raumsonden zu beschleunigen
oder auch abzubremsen
denn wenn die sonne als leichter
körpernah an einem vergleichsweise
schweren himmel
körper vorbeifliegt nimmt sie quasi
energie von ihm so kann nicht nur die
geschwindigkeit sondern auch die
flugrichtung geändert werden wenn die
raumsonde sich wieder entfernt bremst
der planet sie ab das ist tatsächlich
alles eine frage der perspektive
aus sicht des planeten verlässt die
raumsonde ihn mit derselben
geschwindigkeit wie sie sich ihm
angenähert hat eben nur in eine andere
richtung aus sicht der sonne sieht das
alles anders aus so gesehen kommt zu der
geschwindigkeit der raumsonde die
geschwindigkeit des planeten hin zu
relativ zur sonne gesehen ist sie also
effektiv schneller geworden der planet
selbst wird durch die ganze sache einen
minimalen ticken langsamer doch durch
seine gigantische masse im vergleich zu
haben sondern ist dies absolut zu
vernachlässigen niemand kann seinen
geschwindigkeitsverlust in irgendeiner
weise überhaupt messen
doch die fähigkeiten die deswegen bei
schleuder sind begrenzt denn mit der
technik dieses manövers lässt sich die
geschwindigkeit maximal um die doppelte
geschwindigkeit des planeten erhöhen
für interstellare reisen bei weitem
nicht genug und so gibt es verschiedene
ideen um dieses manöver effektiver zu
gestalten hier setzt auch david kipping
an denn er hat sich eine möglichkeit
überlegt wie eine bemannte reise im
weltall mit hilfe von schwarzen löchern
noch schneller werden könnte konkret
schlägt kipping vor schwarze löcher als
spiegel zu nutzen dass die objekte wie
eine art spiegel wirken das weiß man
schon seit 1993 laut kipping müsse
laserlicht sehr gezielt an dem schwarzen
loch das einem entgegenkommt vorbei
gelenkt werden um das schwarze loch
herum befindet sich das sogenannte
photonen
das ist eine zone in der das licht das
schwarze loch ein oder mehrmals umkreis
bevor es hinein stürzt oder den orbit
eben wieder verlässt das licht das dem
schwarzen loch ziemlich nahe kommt
bleibt zunächst in diesem photonen halo
außerhalb dieses bestimmten radius aber
rasters nicht vorbei wird in die
gegenrichtung umgelenkt und das ist der
punkt und kommt so wie ein bumerang
zurück mit einem licht säge könnte das
raumschiff die photonen dann wieder
auffangen vereinfacht gesagt wird also
der effekt dass schwarze löcher wie ein
spiegel wirken und photon wieder zurück
zu ihrer ursprungsquelle schleudern
ausgenutzt skipping nennt diese
ultimative schleuder halo 3 raumschiffe
schießen also laserstrahlen in richtung
des schwarzen lochs und die photonen die
zurückkehren
mit einem segel wieder aufgefangen so
kann an geschwindigkeit zugelegt werden
ohne dass viel energie benötigt wird das
ganze berechnet kipping auch mit hilfe
von komplizierten formeln letztendlich
kommt er zu dem ergebnis dass so eine
endgeschwindigkeit erreicht werden kann
die bei 133 prozent der geschwindigkeit
des schwarzen lochs league kipping hat
riesige visionen schätzungen zufolge
gibt es allein in der milchstraße etwa
zehn millionen schwarze löcher und die
könnten wir kipping zufolge als eine art
express autobahn system nutzen quer
durch die galaxie reisen auf leasing
netzwerken von interstellaren autobahn
und sich von einer station zur nächsten
schießen lassen kipping schreibt auch
dass ein raumschiffen nicht unbedingt
selbst seine eigene laserlicht quelle
mitbringen muss ein entsprechender leser
könnte stattdessen auch auf einem
planeten installiert werden zudem
könnten statt licht auch
teilchenstrahlen also eine art ionen
antrieb genutzt werden schaut man sich
die relativitätstheorie genauer an wird
klar dass es theoretisch gesehen
tatsächlich möglich ist bruchteile der
lichtgeschwindigkeit zu erreichen der
von kipping beschriebene halo 3 sorgt
dafür dass mehr photonen energie zurück
bleibt als anfangs angewendet wird also
in der theorie könnten somit also ganze
planeten massen in bewegung versetzt
werden doch eine der größten
herausforderung wie können wir ein
geeignetes schwarzes loch in
angemessener zeit erreichen david
kipping hat selbst noch keine antwort
auf diese frage doch in zukunft will er
sich bei seiner forschung vor allem auf
diese frage stellen konzentrieren dieses
schwarze loch ist mit bloßem auge
erahnbar sagt neugier zone in diesem
video
ich werde es mir auf jeden fall mit
meinem neuen teleskop mal anschauen und
ihr kriegt am besten dieses video
anschaut es an und abonniert die neugier
zone bis dann bleibt dran